14 millions d'enfants sont morts cette
année dans le monde ils sont morts de
faim ou de maladie autant dire mort de
pauvreté les nations unies ont décidé
que 89 serait l'an 1 des droits de
l'enfance l'unicef leur a emboîté le pas
et demande la tenue d'un sommet mondial
pour parler du remboursement de la dette
du tiers-monde la raison majeure de la
pauvreté des pays jean françois grégoire
l'unicef plus motivé que jamais à vous
néanmoins le développement régressent et
ce sont les enfants déshérités qui paie
14 millions d'entre eux sont morts dans
le monde cette année
principal accusé la dette des pays
pauvres qui atteint la somme
vertigineuse de 1000 milliards de
dollars
un remboursement que ces pays sont bien
sûr incapable d'assumer
chaque année le tiers monde au rang 20
milliards de dollars de plus que les
prêts et les aides versées par les pays
industrialisés ne voyez pas leur dette
les gouvernements réduisent d'autant les
investissements consacrés à la
protection des enfants 50 % de moins
pour la santé et 25% de baisse pour
l'éducation depuis dix ans pour inverser
la tendance l'unicef suggère de
réaménager de façon plus responsable
l'aide au tiers-monde et créer les bases
d'une croissance économique
une opération chiffrée entre 30 et 50
milliards de dollars par an à partir de
malgré ces conditions dramatiques
l'unicef estime que la situation n'a
rien d'inéluctable 2 5% il ya huit ans
la vaccination touche aujourd'hui 50%
des enfants du tiers-monde les maladies
diarrhéiques premières causes des décès
d'enfants diminuent grâce à la
popularisation auprès des parents de la
thérapie par réhydratation orale une
meilleure information permet aussi aux
parents de choisir le moment de la
naissance et le nombre d'enfants un
travail considérable qui permet
aujourd'hui de sauver 2 million et demi
d'enfants chaque année